- On this episode the legend,
and I don't say that lightly,
the legend Michael Ovitz
is in the building.
- This guy cracks me up.
(hip hop music)
- Hey everybody, This is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is episode 293
of The #AskGaryVee Show
and this is gonna be one that I will watch
probably for the rest of
my life every two, four,
five, seven years, 'cause I'm
gonna think of it very fondly.
I don't throw this around very easily,
but an absolute legend has walked in.
The title, this book cover
I'm sure you're seeing it,
for people listening on
the podcast Google it,
Who Is Michael Ovitz is something
that we're gonna answer here.
Please Facebook, I know
you're watching right now,
please put in your phone numbers.
This is a rare opportunity.
Michael is such an icon
and mogul of the culture,
which is what I appreciate
and I'll go into that in a minute,
but at this point of his career
and all the things he's focused on,
the ability to actually ask him a question
is far and few between so
I'm excited that our format
is gonna allow two or three
of you to ask him a question.
And if you know who he is
I'm sure you've got seven
or eight questions lined up,
but for some that don't,
as we start putting down
the blocks in this episode
I think you're gonna get really excited.
Michael thank you so much for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
- For the people that
are watching right now
that don't know who you are,
what is the kind of two to
three minute cliff notes of
who you are professionally, personally,
wherever you want to take it.
- Someone who started out in the mail room
at a large agency and went
off with some partners
to start our own company
and started what I think to
this day 40-plus years later
is the definitive artists
agency in the world.
- And that is?
- Creative Artists Agency.
- So for everybody who's
not from the Hollywood world
or the business world and
you're playing in your own silo,
CAA is a global leader today.
Michael and his partners
left William Morris,
which is also a major player
now with a merger, WME.
In Hollywood land this is royalty.
In every industry I came more
from the liquor business first
and then Silicon Valley culture,
which you've put a big flag in
and we'll get into that later.
But if you're aware of
the LA business scene,
there are no bigger businesses
that have been built
in the talent representation agency world,
CAA is at the top.
And Michael is really...
I have so many friends who are agents
in LA and New York and
other parts of the world
and because of my wine show on YouTube
started having interest in that world,
the amount of times I heard...
in the wine world not as much,
though Michael has a
nice collection of wine.
But as soon as I even
sniffed into anything
that looked like representation
of talent in the world,
the name Michael Ovitz got
thrown around so many times
I was super intrigued and so
many people that I admire,
my contemporaries, really
unbelievably look up to you.
You really...
And I don't know how
you'll answer to this,
but like you absolutely
changed the paradigm of
what a talent agent is and was
and to this day looked upon.
I mean I'm not sure if it's
really been replicated.
Is that something that you think is great,
is that something that you think is
fabricated by the market,
is that over a, you know,
obviously somebody who's an agent
always wants to find that balance
between the talent being at the forefront,
but you became very well-known and a mogul
and did incredible things.
How do you reconcile being in
a place in your life right now
where you can write a book
called Who Is Michael Ovitz
and have it on the cover
and just have so many
people know who you are
and the impact you've
had to such a big part.
I mean I think Hollywood,
Michael real quick,
and I'll stop talking soon,
I think Hollywood is the
great machine of America.
I think America's brand in the world
is actually driven by the
machine that Hollywood was
in a lot of ways Silicon
Valley and social media is now
playing a little bit of that role,
but it's kind of unbelievable
that you were top dog of the machine
that probably allows America
to be top dog in the world.
Do you ever take a step
back and say holy crap?
- You know there's no
time to take a step back
and think about that.
When I decided to write
the book it was more about
trying to have some
record of all the stories
and all the different things that we did.
But to get right to the
heart of your question
about what we did, when we
started in the agency business,
agents basically would
field offers for clients.
They would look--
- They would pick up the phone.
- They'd pick up the phone
and someone would call
and say is Gary available
for such-and-such a day
to do such-and-such a project
and it was pretty much a business
that moved to a pretty slow clock.
And we made a decision while
we were at William Morris
and watched this company,
which was terrific,
a great company, but
suffering from a disease
that all companies do,
which is lack of transition
to younger people
with younger and fresher ideas.
And the more senior people
were running the company
and it was basically stalling out
and we came up with this idea
that it was really important
for the talent to be in the driver's seat.
How do you do that?
How do you get the talent from
being in a second position
to being a first position?
And it was the financers,
the buyers, the studios,
the networks, the publishing
houses, the record companies,
all of whom were in the driver's seat.
And we decided what we can do is
we would start to encourage our clients
to meet with each other, meet
with other creative people,
and pretty much keep all
their ideas to themselves
and their group until
we could take them out
completely as a package.
And by doing that over a period of years
and within a very short period of time--
- What period of time, just for all of us.
- So we started in December of
'74, officially January '75.
And it took us probably...
- Is it true, like I've
done enough homework
and there's been other
books and Google articles
and documentaries,
you guys were planning to
start a little bit later,
but then word within
William Morris was heard
and that's why you guys
had to move quicker?
- Yeah well what happened was,
I went to the City National Bank,
which was a local bank in Beverly Hills
for a $100,000 loan for us to get started
and I didn't think that
they would call the treasurer
of William Morris in New York
and he called the CFO in LA
and he called the president,
they called us and said
you guys can leave,
which moved our plan along a
little faster than we expected.
- So December, January
'74, '75 and then by when?
- By early eighties we
were in the position
where we were selling packaged material
with all of our clients.
- And for everybody you know...
I have a lot of people
who probably don't know
all the Hollywood terminology,
package would be like a big
star with a big director
like what what are the pieces of a package
in the way that you guys created it?
- To us a package was
anything that was built around
what we called a motor.
So you needed one client who was a motor
and let's just take an example--
- Please, use an example,
you have great stories.
So give me a real package.
- Well a real package would have been a...
- You're excited now.
- A real package would have been,
let's just take a simple
one, Ghostbusters.
So Dan Aykroyd is not just
a brilliant performer,
he's a writer and he
came up with this idea
about three Saturday Night Live type guys
running around New York
City chasing ghosts.
And the one line, what you
just did, you have to laugh.
The one line gave the
project simultaneously
to Bill Murray and to Ivan Reitman.
Ivan who was great producer/director.
Ivan had done Stripes with
Bill Murray and Meatballs.
He produced Animal House,
which was one of the
great comedies of all time
and Bill, nobody funnier than Bill Murray.
I mean that sense of humor
is beyond of all time.
I mean beyond extraordinary.
So Bill and Danny and Ivan met
and they decided on Harold
Ramis, may he rest in peace,
it was from Chicago's Second City,
as a co-writer and the third Ghostbuster
and that put together a
complete film right there.
We had three stars, we had three writers,
and we had a director.
- And then you go to
studios and have them,
you reversed the leverage to the package,
which made bids instead of
going and giving the IP---
- Exactly right.
Normally this studio
would come to us and say
we have this script called Ghostbusters.
- And we want your star.
- Well they'd say we want this director,
we want this writer, and
they'd come one step at a time.
We came with the whole thing
completely put together for them.
All they had to do is say yes or no
and we did not give them
much time to say no.
- How quickly did the rest of the market,
so this packaging,
which gave you guys a
competitive advantage
of a new formula to go to market,
did the other agencies
quickly jump on board
and start doing it themselves
or do they kind of sit and
push against it for awhile
and then later succumb
to it and do it as well?
- Well fortunately for us the
competition was slow to react
and in their inability to move quickly--
- Audacity. (laughs)
By the way, it's what's happening
to VaynerMedia right now
in the moments of their audacity
while they scrutinize it,
we land grab.
- All I know is in the two
weeks since I've been up here,
it looks like you have double the staff.
(laughing)
- And so in their slowness...
- In their slowness we
started to sign other clients
and once we had critical
mass of a majority of that,
it was over because you can't
package without the elements
and we had three-quarters of the elements
so there was no competition.
And it was the same
problem for the studios.
They had absolutely the
ability to make contracts,
but we had the creative people.
So what we were trying to do
was keep the creative people
working together and hold their ideas
until we could put them
together completely.
- Facebook if you're watching live now,
I know a lot of you
listening on the podcast
or watching on film, but
if you're watching now
please put in your phone number.
It's an amazing opportunity
to get a question
into one of the legends
of culture in my opinion
obviously because as we
keep going through this
what Michael was able to do and disrupt,
not only in Hollywood...
I'm doing a little of the talking,
bled in by doing some
incredible work for Coca-Cola
and other things and started
to disrupt Madison Avenue
and now in these days,
and we've spent less
time talking about this
so I don't know as much,
but spending enormous
amount of times in SF
with the contemporaries in Silicon Valley.
So in my opinion
because I have context
to both the audience
and Michael's career and what he's up to,
if you were a creator and
you want to ask a question
at a macro and and often if
you're listening or watching
you know how much I talk about
history tells you the future.
I think there's no better time to call now
so put in your phone numbers.
Give Andy kind of your questions.
Andy's looking right now.
So what happens next Michael?
So mid '70s you started
this company with two other,
more than that, right?
- There were five of us.
- Across the way it became kind
of more core like core three
right, for different reasons.
- One of the guys retired,
one of the guys kind of took
a little bit of a backseat,
but he stayed with us,
but it was really Ron Meyer
and Bill Hamer and myself.
- You guys had a core
run for quite awhile.
- We had a good run.
We had a good run.
- It's really incredible, isn't it?
What was the biggest challenge
of running a three-headed monster?
That's tough.
I always say two cooks in the
kitchen is already difficult.
- Well I was really lucky.
I had really good partners
and we all split things up
in a really interesting way.
So Ron was fantastic with
the people inside the company
and also was great with
handling actors and actresses
and Bill, no one better
at putting television shows together.
I mean the guy had this
extraordinary ability
to read material and ideas
and just instantaneously figure out
if he could sell them as TV shows.
And that left me an extraordinarily
wide open field to run
so no one really stopped
me from doing anything
and we had a different idea
every week of what to do,
a different idea and
these guys supported it.
As a matter of fact when we came up
with the idea of working for Coca-Cola
and handling all their advertising,
worldwide ad budget of
over 600 million dollars
and their prior agency
was McCann Erickson.
They had 365 account executives.
We came up with this idea
that we could do this
and do it better and we
could do it for less money
and we could do it with six people.
And Bill Haver came in as
one of those six people
and we produced over 35
commercials a year for 10 years,
including the polar bears,
which still run to this day.
And we did it with something
that is known well today,
but in those days didn't exist,
it's called outsourcing.
- [Gary] Go figure.
- What can I tell you.
We were outsourcing animation,
we didn't have to own all the animators,
we're outsourcing all of the production,
but our clients basically
directed these spots
and we were doing 35 spots
for the cost of seven
that were being done by the large agency.
And it was incredibly well coordinated
and Bill spent an enormous
amount of time on it.
- Michael, let's jump to
the book for a second.
When is the book out?
- Tomorrow.
- Amazing.
- It's out here today,
Gary right in front of you.
- I'm about to sell this, I'm
about to flip this real quick
on the Internet for a margin
because people have to wait.
- You can sell those with your--
- Exactly.
Michael, what's the one
story in here that is either
a clarification, I mean guys,
I'm telling you when you Google,
whether it's Steven Seagal,
it's incredible the breath.
You know what's amazing
about what Michael has done?
A lot of us have careers,
but we're known within our industry.
What's amazing about being a pioneer
and at the tippy-top and I'm
talking number one of Hollywood
is like Ghostbusters everyone's like oh!
Or like my favorite stories
of the old days is like
which actor almost was who?
I think you're Ron
managed Sylvester Stallone
is that correct?
- [Michael] That's correct.
- So I remember somewhere I heard
that Sylvester Stallone was
almost Beverly Hills Cop.
Do you know about this?
- I do. (laughs)
- I mean I don't know what,
listen there's a lot of
things that go on here
that I don't know.
Like I'm asking you, like
there's truth to that, right?
- There's so many movies.
- But tell me that one
'cause that one to me,
when you think Eddie as Beverly Hill Cops
and now you're telling me wait,
Sly was strategically or Ron
or you or whoever was saying
this would be good for your career
because you're so Rambo and Rocky-ed out,
this can show a different side of you.
Just the thought that it was this close
to Sylvester Stallone
being Beverly Hills Cop
I think is fascinating.
- It is true, but you have
to realize that these things,
there are so many films
that had different elements
attached to them and the elements change.
- I get it.
Give me another one Michael
because I could sit for,
because to me that's what everybody...
people like literally in the comments now,
holy shit Sly was almost...
Like what's another one in the 11th hour
that the actor changed
out or somebody said no
and they regretted it forever.
- [Michael] There's one on the book.
- Tell me.
- Schindler's List and Cape Fear
where Spielberg and Scorsese traded films.
Marty developed Schindler's List
and Steven developed Cape Fear.
- That's wild.
- Steven wanted to do Schindler's List
for a whole series of
reasons, mostly personal.
Marty who is one of the...
two of the greatest filmmakers
in the history of the
universe both doing projects
that they basically
decided would be better
if they switch projects.
- That's nuts.
- Yeah like just looking
at all your faces.
So what's story in here because
there's so many stories,
what did you either clarify
and/or what's a story in here
that nobody's heard before?
- Oh, I couldn't even answer that Gary.
There are so many stories
in this book that happened.
The book basically was designed originally
as 10 deals was the name of the book
and that was 10 years ago.
- And you felt that you
could talk, one more time,
and that was 10 years ago?
- 10 years ago.
- So you thought through a
series of telling stories
about 10 specific deals
that you could help
all the entrepreneurs and executives
take the nuances from
these 10 separate deals,
here's a complete package
and a blueprint for you to navigate.
- And what happened while
I was doing it is that
the publisher kept asking
for more information
and as I was working up in the valley,
the brilliant young
people that I work with,
the men and women, they
were asking questions about
why did this work why did this not work?
They were as interested in the mistakes
as they were in the successes.
So I started to write
more and more and more
and the stories went beyond the deals.
They went into actual stories
of the creative process.
You know it's really fascinating
and you of all people
will appreciate this,
how do you define creativity?
I will never forget and it's in the book,
sitting in Japan, I had flown in,
I've been on a 13 hour flight,
went to the hotel, took
a shower, got ready,
went to dinner which is the
middle of the night in LA,
went to dinner in Japan with
the head of Matsushita Electric
and five of his associates.
I was with four of my associates from CAA
and in the course of me literally
having the most extraordinary
time staying awake,
I get asked this question
by this senior Matsushita official:
what is creativity?
Now that question is almost
impossible to answer,
but in a strange way I tried to answer it
or show some peeks of it in the book.
How does a film like Rain Man
or Tootsie or Ghostbusters
or Jurassic Park or Good Fellows.
How do these movies get put
together from a one-line idea.
So it's one line that's verbal
and you look down the road
and three years later you're
watching it in a movie theater.
I will never, till the day
I disappear off the planet,
ever lose sight of what
an extraordinary privilege
it has been to be
involved in that process,
learn the process, be involved with people
that understand the process
and can actually transform
an idea into something you
can read, see, or hear.
- In hindsight Michael, that's amazing,
in hindsight I really
wanted to ask this question
and you're gonna play
it off and be humble,
but I really want you to answer
it so please do this for me.
Now that you can look back on it
and I think about people
I hate like Michael Jordan
and Tom Brady, but this is more business.
Like there's this is the life
of a 42 year old New York fan,
we just happen to luckily
be in the prime eras
of like these players
that are are competitors.
In hindsight what did
it feel like to truly
be at the top of the game
of a game of that size?
I'm sure everybody could
define it differently.
Some may say was an
11-year run, a 3-year run,
a four-day run, I'm not
gonna allow you to dodge it
and say Gary, I never
looked at it that way.
It's inconceivable that you
didn't understand at some point,
holy cow or I'm so glad I did it,
this is what I set out to do,
that you had an era where
you were disproportionately
the most powerful guy in Hollywood.
How does it, do you feel,
now that you look back on
it did you not realize it?
Did it feel like it?
Was an over pressure like
what does it feel like
to be in the eye of the storm
in the white heat moment
for a prolonged period of time
of a game that's so visual?
- So first of all, you do
feel it and you understand it,
the question is do you believe it?
And I never believed it.
I understood it and I'll
tell you why I understood it
because it's really a good question.
I understood it because we had the ability
to get things done that
no one else could do.
So when you have that kind of Midas touch
and you're on what I call a positive role,
which is that everything that
you're touching is working,
the amount of films and TV
shows that we put together,
we had a 15 year run that was unheard of
and I don't think I'll ever be duplicated.
- [Gary] I think that's right.
- We packaged close to 300 movies.
Probably an equal number
of television shows
and you've seen the list of
the films, they're iconic.
Now does that mean that you
let all that go to your head?
We tried to basically
handle it as best we could,
but there are others
around you that make it
that are affected and there
are people that write about you
or people that are jealous
or people that have
been burned in the week
of the power curve.
There's frankly a lot of negatives
that get rolled into
that great big positive.
So for me I used to try
to say to the staff,
we have this giant club,
don't ever, ever touch it.
Don't even reach for it.
Everybody knows that we have this power
to be able to get things made.
When we got Marty Scorsese's
Last Temptation of Christ made,
which no one could touch or get done.
And when we got Rain Man made,
it was a movie that languished
it was put into turn around
by Warner Brothers, which means
they basically rejected it
and said anyone that
wants it could have it.
We went through four directors
and ended up getting it made
and it won six Academy Awards.
These kinds of things prove
that you have the ability,
the issue is there are
people in the wake of it.
- Sure, the collateral.
- It's collateral damage and I must say
the collateral damage was
bigger than I ever estimated.
- And the collateral is multifaceted
'cause it's not just
professional, it's personal.
- No, it's everything.
- That's the thing I think
people don't realize, right?
It's not only your employees
or your competitors,
it is your spouses and children.
There's there's so much collateral
with that kind of white heat.
- It's a sea of collateral damage
and there's not much you can do about it.
I don't know anyone that's experienced
the kind of run that we did
that didn't have the collateral damage.
And one of the reasons I wrote the book
is that I came with the realization
that it wasn't so good
that we had all this collateral damage
and I often ask myself could
we have done it differently?
- And what do you come up with
in your own head nowadays?
- You know this is gonna
be not a popular answer,
but could have done it a little
differently but not a lot.
- Yeah because I think. you
know I apologize for jumping in.
I'm gonna understand that
because as a creative businessman
like look, the reality is I am who I am.
I'm aware that I'm gonna be
in the similar realization,
I already am about things
that have already happened.
- But what you don't
realize is that you're,
it's like throwing a
stone into a still water
and you have a series
of concentric circles.
You don't realize that you're the stone.
So it's not the first concentric
circle that's an issue
or the second or the third,
it's the one way out there
that you don't know exists
and there are people that work for you
and they're all out here,
they're speaking for you.
- [Gary] 100%.
- They don't all say the right thing.
- I default the other way.
I'm really, I mean it.
The way I tried to thoughtfully
think about it over time
is I default into when they
are saying the right thing,
you just can't control certain things.
- So we tried hard to control it
and that's why we were
viewed as controlling
and we were viewed as
having Stepford agents.
- [Nikki] Hello?
- Hello, Niki its Gary Vaynerchuk.
You're on The #AskGaryVee
Show with Michael Ovitz.
- [Nikki] Wow, hello.
- Hi.
- [Nikki] It's an honor.
- What's your question?
Thank you.
- [Nikki] So I guess I
should just ask my question.
- Yeah, that's a good idea.
- [Nikki] I assume. (laughs)
Basically I just wanted to ask
with being with Creative Artists Agency,
what's something that when you work with
a lot of other people kind of high-profile
that you don't want them to do,
that you're like oh this
is a mistake they made,
they could have had been my client but...
- You mean something that
you don't want them to do?
- [Nikki] Like what's a mistake
that when you have artists
who want to be your client,
something that they do that prevents you
from saying yes to them?
- Oh, you mean the other way
when you're at the at the top like a CAA,
what would a emerging
actor/actress/director/athlete say
that could actually
turn off CAA from saying
you know what you're not
the right client for us,
is that the question?
- [Nikki] Correct.
- Interesting.
- I've never...
- The answers always yes,
we want as many clients as possible.
- Normally the answer is yes
so I've never thought about it that way.
- You know what's funny?
It's funny that both the
you and I reacted that way.
A lot of people talk about
be thoughtful about...
you know my team, very senior
people, lots of great people.
We have to be thoughtful
about who we bring in,
they need to be the right kind of client.
I'm like yes, yes, yes,
you know it's funny
that we both reacted that way.
Have you ever had a meeting
where you were court...
let's go this way because
I'd love to hear it,
a play on that question.
Did you ever court somebody
because you're like oh my god,
that would be a crown
jewel or that be a big get
for the firm and I know
you went whale hunting,
was there ever as you were
whale hunting through the years
when you actually got closer
to it you said oh shit,
she or he is such a headache
or they have this vulnerability
or somebody in our stable has
emerged as a direct competitor
and we don't have the bandwidth.
Was there ever, to her point,
was there ever any of that?
- Yeah, we had one situation,
which was really difficult
for us, which is we,
as you've already mentioned,
we handled Sylvester Stallone
and he was very competitive
with Arnold Schwarzenegger
and Arnold was somebody that
I really wanted to represent
because he was, first of all,
he's the most terrific guy.
He's really smart and he really understood
the paradigm of the action
movie better than anybody.
If you look back at his body
of work, it's pretty amazing.
And I went after Arnold and wanted him
and it got back to Sly
and he wasn't particularly happy about it.
(laughing)
- And that's that.
- That was that.
- Is there a reason you're
asking that question?
Are you going through a path or anything
like you're trying to navigate?
- [Nikki] Well the reason why I asked is
because I feel like as
someone who's in Los Angeles
and is along with thousands,
hundreds of thousands of other people,
people always ask oh, what
should I do to get into the door
and so I was like is there
something that I shouldn't do
to what I'm trying to get into the door
because it seems like
everybody has an answer
for how to get into the door,
but not like hey, make
sure you don't do this.
- You know I think short
of anything illegal,
I think anything short
of illegal or immoral,
you should do whatever
you feel you have to do
to move your career ahead.
We were lucky, we went
after talented people,
and at the end of the day talent wins out.
And I think when you're young
you have to look for breaks.
You really have to look for breaks
and they may be social,
they may be business,
they may be because you've got an idea.
Let's not forget we spoke about Stallone,
this guy wrote a script called Rocky
on spec, on his own dime, and--
- [Gary] Sold his damn dog.
- Everybody wanted to buy that
script and move him out of it
and to his credit he
said no me, no script.
- That's hard when your hungry.
- It's really hard and took
a lot of guts to do that
because he was offered a lot
of money for that script.
- The thing that's different today
than some of those years past for Sly
or when you were at CAA is people can now
go direct to consumer.
You can now produce content
and use the distribution
of an Instagram or YouTube
or a podcast to absolutely
give you leverage
to be courted in a very interesting way
in the way that you created packaging
with leveraging the studios,
the human can now create content
to build leverage to
have people bid for them.
- [Micheal] Absolutely.
- That's what happened to
me by the way, real quick,
my little quick CA story
is I started a wine show
on YouTube in 2006 and July of 2007
after showing up on Conan on late-night
because the producers reached out to me
because they were watching it on YouTube,
the next morning I had
an email from Endeavor,
before the merger, William Morris, others.
Everybody ironically but CAA.
Then said on my show that
I was going to Hollywood
to find an agent, it
was like this funny joke
because I thought it was crazy
and then I got an email from
some people that worked at CAA,
they were having a fantasy
football draft that day
and they said why don't you
come and hang out with us.
I said yes, but they didn't
say they were from CAA,
they said what are you doing here?
I said I'm going to see
these Hollywood agents,
they said are you gonna see CAA?
I said no and they made it happen
and that's who I ended up signing with.
That was all based on
me producing a wine show
in a store in Springfield, New Jersey.
There was no moving to
LA and waiting on tables
and going to auditions.
We have an incredible world we live in now
where you can create the leverage for you
on the back of the Internet.
- Different time, completely different.
In our day there were roughly 25 companies
that controlled the complete gate.
In other words the barrier
to entry was severe.
You had seven studios,
you had four networks,
you had five publishing houses,
you had five record companies,
and probably 10 companies in Europe
that controlled everything
that you would read, see, and hear.
Our company had relationships
with all these companies.
If you were a client, you got in the door.
If you weren't a client,
you had trouble getting in the door.
Today, this person that called in
if they could make
something three minutes long
using their iPhone or a small Sony camera,
they could put it up and if it went viral,
good god, who knows?
- Kiki do you love me, the dance,
he's in Drake's video four months later.
One video on Instagram, it goes.
I mean just an incredible time.
- And it's the only song
my three-year-old grandson wants to hear.
- I get it.
(phone ringing)
Who's this?
Brad?
Let's see what brad has to say Michael
and then we'll go back a
little bit into the book.
- [Brad] Good afternoon, this is Brad.
- Brad this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on The #AskGaryVee
Show with Michael Ovitz.
- [Brad] Oh my gosh, I'm having
an out-of-body experience.
(laughing)
- That is a very good thing my friend.
- [Brad] Thank you so
much for taking my call.
- No worries, what is
your question my friend?
- [Brad] Well I know that Mr. Ovitz
you had a tough slog with
Disney that ended poorly,
just wanted to get your comments on
what lessons you took from that session?
- Don't go to Disney.
(laughing)
Now that doesn't include the theme parks,
I happen to like them.
No, as I said in the book,
it's the biggest career
mistake I ever made.
I completely misjudged it
and it's a really good example of how
and why not to be your own counsel.
- It's funny you brought that
up once when we first met
about not being your own counsel
and the value of why
we're sitting together.
For everybody at home just give them
the one to two minute cliff notes.
Obviously the three of us
know what we're talking about,
but I think would be fascinating
for everybody at home.
What is the Disney chapter?
- The Disney chapter is about...
starts with my set of
meetings with Michael Eisner.
It goes through the time
when he had a heart attack
and I stayed in the hospital
with him for five to six days
and he asked me to come on board
to originally be the co-CEO
and that went back down
to being the President/COO
and then it went to be the president
and then when I showed up at his house
for our first meeting prior to starting,
all the people who are
supposed to report to me
he decided weren't gonna report to me.
So it was kind of over before it started.
- Yeah and did you know
that at that point?
- Well I knew it the minute.
- That point you knew.
- I knew it when I was
sitting in his living room
at his house when he had the CFO
and the chief legal officer there
and they said they
weren't gonna report to me
and he didn't do anything about it.
- You said okay, this is--
- Well I mean if he was the CEO
that really wanted this to work
and he wanted a partner.
I mean what we were trying to
do was set up a partnership
the way Bob Daley and
Terry Semel had at Warners
or Don kilo and Roberto
Goizueta at Coca Cola.
Or Tom Murphy and Dan
Burke at ABC Cap Cities.
These were powerful partnerships.
These were big companies.
Disney was about to buy ABC,
it was going to be a behemoth company,
more than one person could run.
So the concept was to create
a dynamic partnership.
- Understood.
Thanks for the call brother.
- [Brad] Thanks Gary, I
wanted to ask quick question,
what do you know about Okanagan wine?
- I know that the Pinot Noir
from that region super intrigued me,
like right before I made the
transition to Silicon Valley
from the wine world I
thought that British Columbia
and Vancouver and Okanagan
region specifically
were making wines that I
thought were world-class,
but nobody knew how to market them.
In the same way that I look
at Baja California Mexico.
I think the two best wines in the world
that nobody knows anything
about are Okanagan Pinot Noirs
and Baja California Cabernets from Mexico
because if you roll up on
anybody and talk about wine
Mexico and Vancouver are not
coming out of their mouth.
So what I know about them is
they're obnoxiously high quality
with absolutely no brand awareness.
- [Brad] Fantastic.
- And I thought Okanagan was in Japan.
- I know you're a big, you know,
you love Japan, huh?
- I love Japan.
- Do you still do you go
there often at this point?
- I haven't recently, but
I used to go once a month.
- Once a month?!
- Once a month, yeah.
- Oh man, that's hardcore.
We're gonna leave it off here.
I want to use the final time for Michael,
I have so many entrepreneurs,
young entrepreneurs,
all ages but I know the base of
who's listening to this show,
a lot of 15 to 35 with plenty older,
but like what's at this point
as somebody who spent the last decade plus
in Silicon Valley culture
and all those leaders,
obviously LA just a man
of the world with Japan
and New York and just you've played it.
You've played it at the highest levels
for the last three, four, five decades.
Like what do you think
is the universal things
that people should be thinking about
regardless of the Internet, not Internet,
regardless of the time, no networks,
unlimited networks with the Internet.
What are the traits or the characteristics
when what you've had is a
really amazing first eye view
into both creative and business titans
that have been able to be successful?
It's not just...
that's what's so beautiful
about the business you had
and much of what I like about Vayner,
it's then I get other
views into the world.
You've had that at the highest levels.
Are there a theme or two of individuals
that are able to succeed
or is there anything that stands out?
- It's a great question.
Nothing has changed for
me from the day I started
in the entertainment
business through today
when I work up in the valley
between San Francisco and San Jose.
It is all about the person.
It's all about the person,
nothing else matters to me.
They could have an idea
that you think is good.
If the person's great,
invest in the person.
Maybe their second or third idea
will be better than their
first, but it's all about--
- Give me a historic story in pop culture
that I think we'd all enjoy
that you so believed in the person
where their first idea wasn't as strong
and the second one was,
they made, I don't know,
Transformers, you know whatever.
- Well you can frankly
look to almost any director
and their early work you know,
but you look at their early work,
it doesn't look anything
like their mature work.
Or you look at some of the
actors that started out,
I mean Sydney Pollack
who is a great director
who was very important to
CAA, started out as an actor
and frankly he wasn't a great
actor when he started out.
He started out with Redford
and Redford turned out
to be a better actor
and Sydney turned out to be
an extraordinary director
who then became a great actor
and if you remember his role in Tootsie
where he played the agent,
which I thought was really kind of funny
since I got to coach him.
And everyone starts out slow
and the careers that to me are the best
are like trains coming out of a station.
I am not big on instantaneous stardom.
I don't think---
- You think it's a vulnerability?
- I think it's a huge vulnerability
because there's nowhere to go but down.
- Can you think of an example of somebody
who's able to calibrate instant fame
and then build on top of that over time?
Does anything come to
mind when I say that?
- Not really.
I mean I don't want to comment
on anybody's career per se,
but I will say that in the music business
it's a big danger right now.
- Yeah one-hit wonder as a first song.
Yeah, it's tough.
And it happens so fast.
- It happens fast, they come and go,
and it's really unfortunate.
We were in the business
of building careers Gary,
we were in the business--
- [Gary] Marathons.
- Well we were in for the long run.
When you meet Tom Cruise at 19
you want to make sure that it lasts,
especially when you believe in the person.
You don't want to have
somebody flame out quickly
and by the way with bringing
up the point that you raised,
when you look at today's world
with instantaneous communication
and 5G around the corner,
it's just too easy to flame out.
- You know what I love about you?
That I have so many
people I interact with,
the fact that I believe that 5G
is one of the most outrageous
technologies that are here,
this is not like wait to, what have you.
And the fact that so few
people are bringing it up
and the fact that you drop
that subtly in this interview
is like I personally enjoy that.
I tend to do things like that,
make references to things,
like do you believe that anybody,
like are you stunned by how few people
understand how big of a technology change
5G is gonna be over the next couple years?
- What I'm stunned by is
how few people in the world
really have grasped the
changes the technology
are bringing right now
beyond what they think.
They think they're big,
but they're humongous
and when they start
looking at what's happening
coming down the road, 5G
is the tip of the iceberg.
Let's get into AI, it's
a whole different game.
I mean the applications for
this are beyond comprehension,
particularly to businesses
that are stratified businesses.
These businesses, these big businesses,
the fortune 500 companies,
this has got to be
at the very top of their
agenda of priorities.
- Yeah but it's not because everything is
Wall Street dynamics and they're trying to
maximize margin every 90 days.
- One of the things I learned early on is
don't think in quarters
and I learned that by
traveling to Asia in the '80s.
Don't think in quarters,
start thinking long term.
Watching how different cultures
react to different things,
the other thing I learned
in Asia, which was great,
is have some respect for your elders
and now that I'm an elder
I like that respect.
- You like that much
more now than back then.
(laughing)
What parting shots, what did
we not cover in this session
that you'd like to talk about
or anything that's on your mind
or things that you'd like
people to think about?
- I think you've covered
pretty much everything.
I mean there's a zillion
stories in The Naked City.
And I've got a lot of stories in the book.
- Let me ask one thing, this,
the four to seven to 11 people
that you gave this book to
already that have read it.
These are clearly people
that have been your friends
for 30 years or a family member,
what's been the feedback
you've gotten from this book
that either feels best
and/or is most surprising
that you didn't see, but three people
have commented on that already?
- Well the person that I gave the book to
through the whole writing of the book
is the person I live with.
Tamara Mellon and she's the
one who would say to me--
- Your full of shit, change that.
- This really stinks.
(laughing)
You know, this is awful,
this is the person who I trust in.
She's been pretty positive
on the end result.
- And how's it feel the
day before the book?
Are you excited?
I mean you were you know...
am I correct like you not...
but you had some, like
you were very interested
in the publishing game back in the day
and like you saw a lot of
opportunity in that space
that other people didn't see.
- We represented usually
half the New York Times
bestseller list on a weekly basis.
- So as somebody who
sat on the other side--
- This has been the
most bizarre experience.
Starting with when I
started talking to you.
I told you that when we talked.
This is insane.
I planned the publicity trips.
I planned all of the different
shows that people would do.
I would supervise anything
that the big authors would do.
And I would sometimes sit in
when they did some of the interviews.
I find this to be absolutely hysterical
that I'm on this side of the
table, I can't believe it.
- If you're watching,
I highly recommend you
pick this up on Amazon
or at your local bookstore.
I have a very funny...
Listen, a lot of you know my spiel.
I'm unbelievably passionate about
history telling you the future
and when you get to see players play it
at the highest level and articulate,
especially in storytelling form,
I know that this audience
especially how it reacts to me
picks up on those nuances.
I think this will be extremely beneficial
to a lot of you whether
you know Michael deeply
or don't know him at all.
I have a funny feeling a
lot of you'll appreciate it
so pick it up, support this man,
and Micheal I appreciate you being on.
- Thank you so much Gary.
- Now, question of the day.
- Question of the day.
- This is our thing for every guest,
you get to ask the question,
what is your question to the VaynerNation?
- My question is pretty simple.
We are in the middle right now
of audience viewership change
and we're dead center in the middle of it.
We come from a world, at least I do,
where we watch things day
and date and now we're in
a world where everything
is streamed on-demand
and I want to know what
the audience thinks
of this new change and what it's done also
to the uniqueness of the
film business with television
and the on-demand world
has kind of taken the spark
out of the film business.
- Yeah, I think that's right.
Michael, thank you so much
my friend, good health.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)